[Music]
the head
means everywhere
I looked at
but nah
we block the time hey ray
so
I would've done
[Music]
I really don't know
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
hey somebody get down before coaching I
am
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie's surprise
there's a brand new trailer for Toy
Story 4 and from what Pixar is saying
this is the final Toy Story movie so
this is sort of the end of an era unless
they're planning on spinning off some
other aspect of the franchise or they
have a TV show that's gonna be coming to
the Disney streaming service so we got
to break it down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing a giveaway
for IMAX gift certificates all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment about the trailer on the
video even though the trailer doesn't
tell you a whole lot about the plot we
do have a synopsis and obviously the
trailer itself introduces a brand new
character played by Tony Hale from
Arrested Development and veep he's
playing a character called forky but
most of you probably detected that he's
actually a spork so he should be called
sporky which seems kind of weird no
surprise Tony Hale was playing a
character that's having an existential
crisis the reason why he's freaking out
is because he feels like he's not a toy
I don't belong here I'm a piece of
silverware people use me to eat their
food but Bonnie the new owner of the
toys as of the end of toys tour III has
turned him into a toy so he's freaking
out because they have this quest that
they're going on which is a little bit
different but he has absolutely no idea
what's going on like I belong in the
drawer the song that they use in the
trailer is also kind of subversive and
melancholy if you really listen to the
lyrics you may have heard it before
because it gets used a lot it's Judith
Collins rendition of both sides now so
remember that this is supposed to be the
last toy story movie the funny Easter
egg here is that the song was also used
at the end of a recent horror movie
called hereditary and just careful for
spoilers for the end of that movie if
you ever plan on seeing it it centers on
this little girl at the end of the movie
a demon comes and possesses one of the
main characters so it's like the end of
Rosemary's Baby where this cult worships
a demon brings it into this world and
you meant to walk out of the theater
feeling like evil has been unleashed on
the world like something terrible has
happened so it becomes this really funny
unintentional reference to that movie
especially when you're watching sporky
freak out like what is going on here
what is this unholy sight that I am
looking at all these toys I'm not meant
to be here if Yuri watch the trailer and
listen to the lyrics of the song it
sounds like it's about a person whose
perspective about something she used to
love like toys in this case has changed
in a bad way and it seems like the
clouds or the toys in this case are
preventing her from doing the things
that she wants to do it almost implies
without actually seeing Bonnie in any of
the trailer footage that she's going
through the same thing that Andy went
through at the end of Toy Story 3
because it's been eight years since Toy
Story 3 came out that's a long time
which obviously was an amazing movie but
it was all about growing up and passing
it on to the next generation so like
Andy passes it on to a very young bunny
like here's all the toys that I'm not
going to be playing with anymore so it
was about leaving your childhood behind
but the actual synopsis for the movie
focuses more on Woody's character it
only says that the toys go on a quest to
find Woody's long-lost love interest
bo-peep so also when you think about the
song in that context it's almost like
being a toy in this group here has
prevented woody from doing the things
that he really wants to do toys like
clouds something that you used to love
preventing you from moving forward in
your life so it's like they're saying
that woody is meant to be with Bo Peep
but something like being a toy in this
group here has prevented him from
seeking her out to do that that's why
the poster seems so ominous this is the
official poster and it's woody doing his
so long partner pose as he sort of walks
off into the sunset like it's his last
hurrah goodbye everybody as he walks
away let me know in the comments would
you guys think about the trailer the
movie isn't coming out till next summer
so we'll get a bunch more trailers
before then that'll tell us what the
actual plot is we'll see if Toy Story 4
is able to top Toy Story 3 because Toy
Story 3 is probably one of the best
movies in a franchise of all time
usually movies do not get better with
sequels but Toy Story 3 is just one of
the best movies of the franchise just in
general it's okay
it'sjust I wish I could always be with
you you will be one
[Music]
but more to the idea of turning things
that aren't toys into toys Robot Chicken
did this exact same thing in a parody
episode a couple years ago here's a clip
from that guys look what Andy's aunt got
him from Gwyneth Paltrow's website say
hi
to pink oh hello what are you I am a
Swedish creativity object designed in
conjunction with free space theory which
encourages cognitive freedom for
instance your cowboy concept restricts
imaginative thinking whereas I am
conceptually neutral andy chooses what i
am not the manufacturer i already hate
this prick hey stop that we're all
friends here mr. Potato Head pink oh let
me be the first to welcome you and shake
your hand how can I shake your hand with
your hand right there who said that's a
hand maybe on a magical train and that
hand is a wheel maybe on a candy making
machine or a hotel for tiny clowns my
concept will come from Andy's brain not
yours oh no need to get upset man man
how dare you maybe I'm a woman maybe I'm
in a sexual space creature Andy should
decide and not be forced into your
narrow violent worldview violent we are
not violent toys really what is that
holster used for probably not organic
fruit snacks and I bet that laser isn't
meant for pointing to things in a
classroom setting that is a
Tyrannosaurus Rex aka nature's perfect
killer and you're the most frightening
toy of all what because of my acerbic
point of view you keep body parts in
your trunk you know who else did that
Jeffrey Dahmer and didn't you strap a
bear to the grille of a truck to teach
him a lesson who are you the Mafia hey
Shh Andy's coming
I can't wait to begin growing creatively
with Andy I am pink oh you decide what I
am okay you're trash hey can someone
give me a hand who says these are hands
you are going right in the garbage
that's really more of a send-up of
Gwyneth Paltrow and her goop brand than
the Toy Story franchise but it's a good
example of what they're doing with the
Toy Story movie turning things that
aren't toys into toys with sporky but
what will happen is is they just dropped
a new trailer for Ryan Reynolds
detective Pikachu there's actually a
Deadpool Pikachu if you guys haven't
seen that so I'll do a trailer breakdown
for that that should be up in the next
couple of hours
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
that you may have also seen new sites
reporting the Stan Lee passed away this
morning at 95 years old there's no limit
to the amount of praise that we could
heap on him and the impact that he had
on the comics community he was an
amazing person so I don't know if I'm
gonna make a video about him or anything
like that but I just wanted to honor him
a little bit during this video click
here to learn about the alternate ending
from Avengers infinity war and click
here for my new Avengers 4 teaser video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]